Transcription: Julie Sigwart
Relecteur: eric vautier
Permaculture d’infrastructures ?
Avez-vous déjà entendu parler
de la permaculture ?
Un mode biologique,
une façon un peu
New Age de nourrir la planète,
une philosophie naturelle
pour préserver Gaïa...
Je suis sûr que vous avez
déjà entendu parler de la permaculture.
Mais les autoroutes ?
Autoroutes... autoroutes des vacances,
les camions, le travail
le jour, la nuit, la pluie, le soleil...
Je suis sûr que, au moins une fois dans
votre vie, vous avez pris l’autoroute.
Mais alors...
la permaculture et nos autoroutes,
quel lien peut-il y avoir entre les deux ?
Quand on confronte
ce concept de permaculture
et le concept d’autoroute,
qu’est-ce qui peut bien se passer ?
Ou, plus largement, la permaculture
et les infrastructures :
quel rapport peut-il y avoir entre les
infrastructures et la permaculture ?
Je m’appelle Frédéric Rousseau,
je suis ingénieur et poète.
Depuis plus de 30 ans,
je travaille à rapprocher
des infrastructures et les territoires,
et l’une et l’autre qui se nourrissent.
J’ai fait ça en France, mais aussi au
Pérou, en Colombie, en Grèce.
Tout d’abord, regardons de plus près
ce concept de permaculture.
Qu’est-ce que la permaculture ?
C’est un concept qui consiste à prendre
soin de la Terre et des humains,
dans le respect de la vie -
le fondement, c’est le respect de la vie -
et de générer des surplus
qui soient un partage équitable
entre la Terre et les humains,
mais aussi qui soient un partage équitable
au sein même des communautés humaines.
Donc prendre soin de la Terre,
prendre soin des humains
dans le respect de la vie,
et générer des surplus
dans un partage équitable.
Voilà le fondement de la permaculture.
Mais la permaculture, c'est aussi
une science et un art.
C’est un art de contemplation,
d’observation, de placement.
C’est une science aussi, cette observation
avec un retour d’expérience,
de l’expérimentation,
de la publication, du partage.
La permaculture est simultanément
un art et une science.
Explorons le design permaculturel
avec le Cube d’Aladin, cet objet.
La première étape dans le design
permaculturel, c’est d’entretenir.
le E de « Entretenir ».
On part de ce qu’on a et on entretient,
dans l’observation, progressivement,
de bien comprendre ce qui se passe.
Et puis l’étape suivante,
une fois qu’on maîtrise bien l’entretien,
c’est de « Renouveler ».
On va renouveler l’existant
au fil des saisons,
ce qui va donner encore de la connaissance
complémentaire par l’observation.
Et seulement quand on aura compris
l’entretien et le renouvellement,
alors on pourra « Créer ».
Contrairement aux projets usuels,
on se projette de suite pour créer.
Le design permaculturel,
c’est d’abord Entretenir, puis Renouveler
et enfin Créer.
Deux autres aspects
du design permaculturel,
ce sont les principes d’attitude.
J’ai choisi un principe d’attitude :
c’est le questionnement et l’observation.
On est face à une situation
et on va observer;
simplement observer et se questionner :
« Pourquoi ci ? Pourquoi ça ? »
Ça se passe forcément au fil des saisons.
Ce n’est pas en un mois qu’on comprend
comment fonctionne une culture,
comment fonctionne un paysage,
comment fonctionne un écosystème.
Ensuite, il y a des
principes de conception.
J’en ai choisi trois :
les deux premiers, c’est la redondance
et la versatilité.
Ce que j’ai dessiné, c’est une fonction.
Et plusieurs objets
remplissent la même fonction,
donc si un objet est un peu moins solide
que les autres, la fonction va être tenue.
La versatilité, elle,
c’est qu’un seul objet remplit
plusieurs fonctions simultanément.
Et quand on assemble simultanément
la redondance et la versatilité,
les objets et les fonctions
vont s’entremêler
et on va aboutir à un système.
La systémique est une science inventée
il y a plus d’une cinquantaine d’années
et qui se retrouve au cœur
de la permaculture :
la capacité à faire
des systèmes résilients
par la combinaison
entre la redondance et la versatilité.
Le troisième principe de conception,
c’est tout ce qui relève de l’espace :
le zonage, le voisinage, le placement
et les interconnexions.
Ce sont ces interconnexions,
bien placées entre des objets
qui sont placés au bon endroit,
des pratiques qui vont être les bonnes,
bien placées dans le temps et l’espace,
qui vont créer ce système interconnecté.
Voilà des éléments
de design permaculturel.
Maintenant, regardons quelques exemples
d’application de design
permaculturel aux infrastructures.
Tout d’abord, prenons une métropole :
Toulouse, Paris.
Vous avez des réseaux de voies rapides
et vous avez des réseaux ferrés.
Une approche de design permaculturel
entre la versatilité et la redondance,
c’est comment utiliser mieux ces réseaux.
Pour utiliser mieux ces réseaux,
comme ça existe à Madrid
depuis plus de 15 ans,
c’est de mettre des bus
sur les autoroutes.
Mais pas juste un bus
au milieu des voitures,
ce sont des bus sur des voies rapides.
Ces voies rapides qui permettent de
converger au plus vite vers la ville,
mais dans un maillage.
Par exemple, depuis plus d’une quinzaine
d’années, sur l’A10, à côté de Paris,
il y a une gare de bus,
et les bus vont à la gare de Palaiseau.
Et là, ensuite, on prend le RER
et on peut aller dans Paris.
Là, c’est un exemple de design de comment
tirer plus des infrastructures existantes,
en mettant ces bus sur des voies
rapides, sur les autoroutes,
avec un bus à haut niveau de service
qui va permettre de transporter
mieux les personnes
mais avec aussi une bonne attractivité.
Un deuxième exemple, tout récemment,
ce sont les dépôts de bus de la RATP.
La nuit, ils sont pleins
de milliers de bus
et le jour, ils sont vides,
ils ne servent à rien.
Versatilité ?
Eh bien, dans la journée,
ce dépôt de bus va servir
de centre logistique
pour toutes les livraisons de colis
sur le dernier kilomètre.
Et on voit bien, en temps de Covid,
la multiplication
de toutes ces livraisons.
Eh bien, l’intérêt de ce design,
c’est d’utiliser le dépôt de bus
pour faire de la logistique,
sans créer un autre objet à côté
qui serait le centre logistique,
qui serait à côté du centre de bus.
Ça, c’est quelque chose
qui est en train de se mettre en place
par la RATP, en région parisienne.
Et puis, si on prend du champ
sur quelque chose d’un peu plus large,
imaginons une rencontre
entre le mot « autoroute »
et le mot « poreux ».
« Autoroute poreuse »
Qu’est-ce que ça peut bien être ?
Qu’est-ce que ça peut nous apporter ?
On voit bien les échangeurs,
les voitures qui rentrent et qui sortent,
mais ce n’est pas très poreux, cela.
Eh bien, il y a des aires de service.
Et sur les aires de service,
on va mettre un portillon dans le grillage
qui va permettre de rentrer
et de sortir de l’aire à pied.
Il n’est pas question de créer
une entrée pour les voitures en plus.
Et ce portillon dans le grillage,
il permet aux personnes
qui habitent les territoires
d’utiliser les services
de l’aire de service
sur des produits de première nécessité,
aller prendre un pot...
Il permet aussi aux clients de l’autoroute
de pouvoir sortir et d’aller
se promener dans le territoire,
découvrir quelque chose de différent
à pied, toujours, ou à vélo,
s’ils ont des vélos avec eux.
Avec l’avènement du véhicule électrique,
les temps de recharge seront
bien plus longs.
Et plutôt que rester une demi-heure
au pied de sa voiture,
il est possible d’aller faire
un petit tour à pied
en dehors de l’autoroute.
C’est la rencontre des mots
« autoroute » et « poreux ».
Et en explorant ce concept
d’autoroute poreuse,
on doit pouvoir aller beaucoup plus loin.
Revenons à notre cube d’Aladin.
On a vu les lettres : le E, le C, le R.
« Entretenir », « Renouveler », « Créer ».
Mais les « R », quand on regarde bien,
il y en a deux
Il y a deux « R ».
C’est quoi, ce deuxième « R » ?
Le deuxième « R », c’est « Raconter ».
Il est essentiel de raconter votre projet.
Un projet, c’est l’assemblage
d’histoires individuelles
qui vont se rassembler
dans un récit collectif
qui va nourrir un rêve partageable.
J’ai bien dit « partageable »,
pas « partagé ».
Un rêve partagé,
c’est au sein d’un tout petit groupe;
Le rêve partageable,
il va pouvoir se propager.
Une des clés du design permaculturel,
c’est la capacité à raconter
la transformation à venir,
à raconter les constats,
à raconter l’observation,
dans des cercles extrêmement larges,
de diverses cultures,
de diverses origines, de divers intérêts.
Donc « Design permaculturel
d’infrastructures ».
C’est une méthode qui s’ajoute
aux méthodes traditionnelles.
Il est évident
qu’on va continuer à utiliser
le savoir-faire capitalisé
de conduite de projet,
le savoir-faire en concertation.
Il y a des méthodes extrêmement robustes
qui sont en place.
Mais le design permaculturel,
cette démarche de design permaculturel,
va permettre d’identifier
un champ des possibles bien plus large.
Alors, je vous invite à expérimenter,
avec l’aide du cube d’Aladin,
cette approche de design permaculturel,
pour rendre un territoire plus harmonieux
au service des habitants.